好的 那個我覺得這樣 今天我講三個話題吧
一個是就是到了weakness
是不是資金在流出美國
然後美元走落的這個趨勢
尤其是對歐元對日元這個趨勢是不是趨勢性的趨勢
然後在外匯市場上大家會覺得會怎麼樣
這是我們以前FICC的老本行嘛
我待會講一下這個觀點
然後第二就是最近其實
最近一兩個月了吧
所有的討論都是集中在對於特朗普的關稅政策
那麼這個關稅政策前後發動
然後到現在就最近的一些變化吧
其實這個關稅政策的變化也導致了上一週的這個市場的變化
就上週大家覺得關稅各方面的話
有一些緩和
所以整個市場在跌了8個星期了
跌了7、8個星期之後最後終於是
開始反彈了一下
然後除了這個市場反彈之外
第三個我想講一下就是製造業回到美國的問題
因為這個事情上兩週有很多的討論嘛
然後我是覺得製造業是很難回到美國去的
先說一下上週的市場
上週的市場我覺得最大亮點是NASDAQ上升了一個星期上升了6.5
就是NASDAQ這個反彈還是比較明顯
其實這個中間背後有幾方面的原因嘛
我們可以看一下CTA的這個Position
其實一直以來從大概4月份開頭
我們就會看到所有的這個CTA和bock control
這兩種叫做趨勢性策略
那麼這些趨勢性策略基本上都是空散或者是已經到了歷史地點
這個代表就是說趨勢性策略補他又會再去賣空
然後他們只會買入
所以其實我當時一直在說嘛
市場有一個就是很強的壓力到了一個極限
在短期後的一期是一直到了一個極限
那麼兩週因為中間還有經歷了很多Trump給出的這些政策
包括他對中國加稅 包括Cypical Tariff
包括他那兩回會發了各種各樣的推特
還有True Social 發了很多True Social
所以市場在很大壓力下面被壓得更厲害了一下
但是這些壓力還是會釋放
所以我們看到上一週的話買了26個別鏈
就是CTA和bock control的策略
大概買入了26個別鏈的股票 就是那個acquity
所以這一些是中間一個比較重要的原因
那麼啟動是由於美國TMP的Earning比較好
就TMP的Earning也不是說Earning特別好
比方說谷歌的那個Cloud Service
它的這個語音的服務其實first quarter是inline的
增加29%是inline
但是整體大家對於TMPEarning的預期其實比原來更低了
也就是說市場的position是一個更加
進加謹慎更加友好的一個position
並不像今年年初的時候大家預期後面的這個Earning adjustment
就Earning就盈利的這個預期會不停的得到高估
不停的得到高估現在大家市場沒有這個預期了
所以就是給到了這個市場一個
就TMP的Earning給到市場一些surprise吧
會讓大家覺得雖然搞了很多terror
然後我們那個Trump在瞎折騰
但是似乎還沒有對科技公司的盈利造成什麼影響
確實我們之前也講過
我覺得科技公司的盈利其實未必會受到這麼大的影響
特別是後面我們會看到半導體
半導體和行業的這個
我們至少從eq從谷歌的這個Campus上面來看的話
半導體行業可能也不會受到特別大的影響
但是它之前跌是跌了很多
就是我們會認為就是它以前大家對它earning adjustment
對它這個盈利的預期的上升的這個預估會比較多
覺得它盈利預期只會往上上調
那麼出了這個terror of policy之後
大家覺得經濟可能會著落
然後大家覺得所有的盈利預期全部要下去
所以一方面主要是殺估值殺預期
但是接下去這個階段
特別是對於半導體和高科技公司
可能會看到的至少在幾個月裡面
它的earning不會受到太大的影響
那麼真的是衰退了
會影響一下谷歌這些廣告投入
包括Amazon這些廣告投入都是會影響的
但是這個影響可能要等到真的衰退出來才會影響到
所以接下去殺估值或者是殺P
相對各個Sector跟不同的版塊來說
其實科技版塊的這個
我一直說科技版塊相對於其他版塊來說
可能更加防守性一些更加defensive一些
這個是因為前一段時間其實已經跌過了
那麼為什麼說半導體這樣的
因為第一個Kapex來看
比方說谷歌這兩天Meta和Amazon也要爆
那個谷歌是75個別臉投入2025年
這個沒有變化
就預期大家覺得它可能會不會開年不會
那麼其實大家更多的關注是2026年的這個Kapex
那麼2026年Kapex是怎麼樣的
谷歌給了一個信號
其實它當時說的是就是Shelf Supply
就是整個半導體行業市場裡面
包括在算力裡面其實Cloud Service為主
這個就是我們叫Kapex AI這個賽道
還是供應不足
在這個情況下
這麼大不確定情況下
因為不確定帶動的是應該Kapex減少
帶動的是大家不敢投資
在這種情況下谷歌給出這個信號
說是Tight Supply Environment
原話這麼說的Tight Supply Environment
那麼並且它給出了
它那個谷歌有一個叫AI Overview Page
使用的人大概是1.5個別臉permonth
就15億人permonth
所以它就給出了這些預期
就是讓市場就是情緒得到一些緩解
但是雖然這個緩解有這樣的緩解
但是大家對於整體給PE估值是非常非常謹慎的
我們看到投資人給那個美股的PE估值很謹慎
為什麼呢
因為畢竟的這個我們待會會講
第二個話題就是川普的這個政策
其實並沒有得到
川普的政策並沒有得到很多的緩解
大家對他的未來的東西不確定
所以不確定的時候就推動美股
上升很大程度上
比如說這兩個就是很重要的
一個就是CTA策略是很重要的
那個Volk Control和CTA
那現在Volk其實是下不來的
因為你不確定嘛
所以Volk很難下來
所以這些CTA策略很難加上去
就是我們在去年或者是前年吧
這兩年裡面看到的美股的拉一條直線的上漲
這背後有很大原因就是
Volk Control一起進去加工感
然後更多的市場的可預測性
然後包括政府的消費
經濟通段被控制住以後
政府的消費帶動整體市場
這樣上升
但是這個環境現在在
在Trump administration裡面肯定是不可能的
因為現在我們看到Vix
上週另外一個市場反彈了一個重要的信號
是Vix就Volk被relax
大家覺得那個Volk下來一些了
但是也是在20左右
你想我們去年在談的時候
Vix可能在12
在這麼一個水平上
就是我們叫做已經沒有空間了
就是這個Vix就是賣期權
已經賣到沒有空間了
那現在能在20幾
其實這個說明就說市場
並沒有給到
就是像有可能像去年這樣
完全的反彈一條直線的這個走勢
是非常非常困難
只是說這幾個星期以來
市場的position非常clean
毆存很clean
因為大家該空的都空了吧
我們會看到那個
嗯
這個跟那個外貨市場很相似
就是我們會看到大規模的頭寸
其實特別是對沖基金層面
該做空該跑的跑了非常快
一下子就跑完了
所以現在呢
很多的是shock cover
那在那個補標上面都是shock cover
然後把那個價錢帶回來
那麼更加長期的
包括上週還有一個原因
就是10年的rate
10年rate被穩在的C25左右
所以這也是一個讓市場
就我之前也說過
就是說美債其實是沒有很大的風險
今年特別是沒有供應面的風險
美債的這個大規模下跌
其實我覺得不會
嗯
不會是一個
不會是像一個美股一樣控制不住的
就是你如果發生很多風險
然後債券有這個
另外國內盛傳兩個
兩件事情嘛
盛傳一件事情
說那個美國年中有大量的債券到期
然後這個問題我可能上週
不然再上週講過
就是說大量債券到期
這個是新的
就是新的monthly supply
你可以看到5月份的這個supply
就馬上要有的
其實只有
就是新增的 net issuance
只有31個面
devil one
只有三十一個
三千一百萬
所以你會看到整個債券發行的
它預期的發行量其實非常有限
那個市場消化大根本不是什麼問題
那個美國說
美國這個新聞
可能最早是從中國出來
說美國年中有大量的債券到期
所以這個債券率率要被拋售
這個我覺得純粹無極之談
那其實債券市場
還有一個最近的無極之談
我一起提報一下
那個就是好像是zero high就說吧
說那個truxury爆了那個
Borni的就是需要借的債的量下降很多
所以國債利率下降
這個其實也不是
就是國債利率本身5月份的話
它的發行量就是會下了很多
第二就是truxury爆的
那個Q2的390個別鏈
沒有什麼問題
它並不是削減了什麼製作
它主要是6月30號的
那個6月30號的decilyn要到了
那麼decilyn一直要到了
它其實一直在花tg的錢
本質上就是它coupang的發行沒有變化
維持在原來的計劃中間
但是它的發的短期佔其實發少了
那把那個tg的錢
就我們叫truxury general account
recall一下
大家有一些可能不記得了
就是說那個財政部的錢是存在央好的
所以如果發債的規模受到限制
它等於把它存在央行的錢拿出來用
存在央行那個錢就是叫做tg
那等於把存在央行錢拿到了商業央去
那其實等於是增加了市場流動性
所以這個過程就是消耗tg
然後增加了市場流動性
他們本來的計劃等到6月30號
decilyn到期以後
然後再把那個短期債發行
然後再把這個tg給補上
但是現在我感覺6月30號達成一個
債務上線的truth
債務上線的這個條款
我覺得非常困難
不是那麼容易一件事情
不是那麼tribble
所以這個tg的過程還會繼續
但是並不是說這個debug
就是我覺得說一下這個事情
這並不是說財政部報的這個債務需求減少
其實我們沒有看到這個
做出很實質性的檢視字的政策
那這也是我覺得是還沒折騰到那裡
還沒實質性檢視字
所以現在特朗普
我們認為三個可能爆發雷
只是爆發了tariff這個政策
那麼回過頭我評價一下
美國和中國的這個tariff
特別是其實這中間主要是中國和美國
那樣子
美國希望製造業回到美國
所以這是特朗普他們的核心政策
然後對於中國去加稅
那麼希望製造業回到美國
我把這兩問題一起說
我覺得第一製造業肯定回不到美國
不管他採取什麼樣的政策
都是不可能回到美國權
這有各方面的原因
我待會再結束
但是他開始這場關稅戰
就是希望不管他是出於政治原因也好
出於什麼原因也好
開啟這場關稅戰
他完全低估了中國
低估了全世界的反應
所以他是完全沒有做好準備
那麼我覺得現在處於雙方低估
就是美國低估了這個產業鏈
產業鏈的困難度
和對中國的依賴程度
以及中國可能對他反應
這全部低估了
那麼他所以這次採取的關稅戰
就是在開頭大概率是糊塗舌吻
草草收場
草草未必會收場
就是會草草
這是我個人的判斷
因為這個我也不是政治評論家
所以我只能說
這個是我個人的判斷
那這個判斷的
導致了我後面對整個市場
可能會比較悲觀
就是不管短期裡面有這樣的反彈
那我都沒有特別的看好
或者是積極的參與
那我還是維持的
可能現在一部分的美股的倉位
那我也沒有動
那我就維持在那裡
我就看著他怎麼弄
但是如果是特朗普
徹底把關稅政策也放棄掉
而我覺得不太可能
徹底把關稅政策放棄掉
那所有的這個看法就全部改變
就像我們今年年初講的
就對於政治上的一個判斷
政策上的判斷
你只能做一條切線去預測
那麼他對於這些東西的低估
導致現在自己陷入一個很尷尬的境地
但是我覺得中國的反饋
也低估了
中國其實一直做好了
美國可能關稅政策的準備
對於轉口貿易
這個外貿公司怎麼去
規避美國關稅
這些東西很有一套
2017年以後中國其實做好了很多準備
然後甚至對於美國關稅家的
很嚴重以後有各種各樣的預案
其實中國相對於關稅戰的準備
會比美國好很多
但是中國現在也低估美國的決心
這個是我覺得
雙方都在低估的一個事情
所以中國現在的反應就是
我覺得你一下對所有人開展
沒做好準備
你一開被我打了一個先手
那我就先追逐你
最好能達成一個比較好的貿易協定
中國不會太輕鬆的去鬆脫的
因為美國現在比方說意識到了
稀土它沒有 對吧
然後各種各樣的零部件它都沒有
那個5月2號就是我當我講一下
川普關稅的一些relaxation
那5月2號他可能對於
那個autopot都要開始
現在說是好像我今天早上看新聞
是說要發reimbursed
發那個回補
那麼之前的新聞有炒作的說
要把中國的這一部分
要豁免一些那個機車零部件
所以你就好像一個工廠
你把那個車間那個中間給割掉一塊
你要說其他的人來修
來把這個車間給補上
整個工廠全部要停工的
然後要補上
要契合要對接
做過工程師的人
就知道這個事情是不可能
那麼快完成的
任何一個小細節都要搞錯
就一個東西要調通是很複雜的
那個一個東西要把它
那個破壞掉以後再調通
這個是非常非常大的工程
你需要先把這個東西調通了
再備案
但是你又不可能有這樣的一個做法
你就是硬搞
硬搞之後
催斷的這個影響是會很大
你要知道中國和美國的這個貿易的情況
首先全球貿易是平衡的
就你把地球全球來看
這個東西它是平衡的
也就是說快到瓶頸了
你就靠的是美國不停的
美國輸出什麼
美國輸出它是駐弊權
它一直在印美金
但是它快到極限了
就是全球來說
整體的產品是供應過剩的
所以中國這個供應過剩
確實是一個非常頭大的事情
中國不可能再增長了
因為全球的需求
被你全吸光也沒有辦法
也沒有辦法滿足你的供應
美國不願意
加上美國現在不願意
所以全球來說
somehow是balance
但是 leaning towards over supply
就是 leaning towards這個供應過剩
所以中國這個通縮是
中國永遠是漫年以方
所以這個問題很大
但是你在這個體系中間
你要把它打破
把這個供應辦到美國去
那面臨三方面幾方面的問題
其實你簡單看看
因為整個產業一個工廠
你要建起來做過產業
都會很簡單
這是第一個
製造業本身是ROI的有機
把錢投進去
把電和人
就是把礦和人變成產品
那麼最基本的礦就是電網
中國用美國用Gas
美國Natural Gas
你看發電量
中國是美國一倍
這個並不是一天能夠翻上去
這個是通過幾十年的努力
幾十年的不停的投資
不管是國家投資
境外投資
然後電網投資
這一系列的東西
中國電網至少領先美國20年
15年20年
這個是幾十年這種投入帶來的
這個東西
我們認為一旦你超越了
你很難再一旦被超越
你很難再超越
需要巨額的組織性的投入
這種在所有西方社會是不太有的
所以你如果要把中國整個需求減少
中國會打下來
那就說他們維持中國被打下來
中國會吃很多的苦
但是你要replace
再把自己抬上裙
那可能是沒有了
第二工業機器人
你看這個是23年
其實每年都這個一樣的
每年的數字大概就差不多
工業機器人
你就看看就知道了
就是說這是代表工廠
先進工廠
工廠裡面用的機器人
誰買了更多
這個是持續不是一年
從2017年開始到2023年
每一年
配合著這個發電量
所以這個是礦
這是你的生產資源
你生產勞動力的
勞動力靠的是人
美國沒有人礦
美國現在就業情況
已經基本上互implement了
你其實美國的人口
連攔牆計銷都沒有
你要做製造業
你要這些人投入到製造業裡面
第一個要有人
你現在沒有人
你哪怕哪被把移民過來
你分外移民政策都沒有
你把原來不工作那幫人
因為美國的implement是
有工作的廚藝
就是他bass是願意找工作的
或六個月之內有工作的那些人
就是尋找工作人群
你把這部分人群如果想擴大的話
你有沒有技巧
你有沒有一個教育體系
把這些人轉換過去
中國有藍領工人
那個人群不足的問題
但是相比較美國來說
還是好很多
美國完全沒有
這個是美國的obese population
就是它的肥胖症
肥胖症的定義是BMI超過30
你看它40%人在肥胖症中間
當然現在可能人家說可以用smeagolota
但是本質上就是說
你要知道這是大部分的人口
它不在勞動人口中間了已經
你沒有人
你有礦就有礦
但是你有礦你變不成電
你等於沒有礦
然後你也沒有人
所以這兩種情況
製造業怎麼可能回到美國
製造業回美國
我覺得這個基本上是個謬亂
這個不太可能的
所以這個事情開頭美國難
但是後面的中國
不好意思
我這個信號手不太好
開頭美國難
後面中國也會非常難
後面中國為什麼難
因為很簡單
所有的global的需求
會在這個貿易體系下面下去
也就是這又回到了
我們雖然就好像一戰的時候
那個大家雙方開戰
覺得可能三個月解決戰鬥
但三個月沒解決戰鬥
是一個temporary truth
就短期的一個停戰
還是說繼續想辦法再打下去
修修補補再打下去
這個是這兩個東西中間的糾結
不停的一個推進的過程
最後搞了四年
就是這個一戰就是這個樣子
大家沒有準備好打
其實
那麼沒有準備好打那麼長的戰爭
把自己打
把大家都打傷掉
那麼現在中國和美國
也在進行各種各樣的談判
tereft的談判
就是truth的談判
那麼這些truth的談判中間修修補補
我覺得還會打下去
本質的原因就是
特朗普的基本盤是GOP
是馬卡
他要通過馬卡的基本盤
來維持他的GOP
就是共和黨黨內的領導地位
他不太在乎
共和黨是個當選
就是他反正不能選第二任了
他要在乎的是
共和黨黨內的這個領導地位
他要套號的是馬卡
這種情況下面
修修補補會打下去的
所以這個就是
這是我的一個Long term的
Million term
一個看法
所以在這個Million term看法中間
市場是不會太好
這個是有一個趨勢
那麼對於資金是不是流出美國
那麼或者說美元
是不是進入一個長期的
就是那個depreciate的過程
特朗普的政策
如果是這樣的話
美國在美元在Million term
是要變成
那個是跟我們年初的時候的看法
是居然不同了
那特朗普政策
我先把特朗普政策簡單說一下
因為上週這個信息
大家那個人來回回很多
特別是在中國和美國中間
有很多就是感覺
好像要降溫的
中美之間要降溫的這個
一些信號
阿巴森和那個Trump
其實都出來說了
就是要中國給一個態度
然後那個所有的言論
都不再做升級
這個是上一星期
我們叫de-escalation
包括市場樂觀的一個態度
但是美國現在在scramble
就是在那個草草
希望彈成一個template
因為現在很多國家
都要跟他談這個tariff
每個國家都一起談
是不可能
跟一個正常的
一個貿易的關稅的談判
是以年為計的
他現在要幾個星期談出來
就是草草要談出來
他必須要做一個template出來
做一個那個mobiat出來
他現在想跟印度
和那個日本韓國談一個template出來
所以這個是另外一個
他們在推進的事情
那能不能談出來呢
我覺得比較難
其實大家都在
這個事情本身就沒有辦法
很快完成
包括人家還要去
中間會有新聞
做出template的樣子
但是最後能談
我真的能談完
我不覺得能問話
然後第三樂觀的兩個方面
就是
一個就是celeter有可能會
就是參議院有可能會vote去block
就是把那個特朗普的這個
iEPA給停掉
就是他等於是宣布了一個
國家緊急狀態
他就是那個
那個國家
國家那個就是那天宣布的時候
就說4月2號的時候
宣布了國家緊急狀態
所以他可以放很多的
很多的關稅上去
沒有過議會
那麼celeter是希望
把這個東西給取消
celeter可以通過
那麼通過之後
18天以後
那個緊急狀態就被取消了
但是
house現在就是
眾議會
house是被republic控制的
所以house裡面我覺得過不了
所以celeter
那個參議院通過
基本上只是一個刑事性的
第二就行政和立法的問題
那個現在CIT
包括CIT和很多
就是multiple court cases
就是那個法院的case
在駁回總統的iEPA的
這個對於關稅的一個決定
那麼我覺得就算
spirin court就是最高法院
判決了總統駁回的總統iEPA
iEPA就是那個緊急條約
那個緊急條約
但是我覺得
不太會影響他的行政
因為他有很多的其他的變動
美國的這個總統的
可以行使的緊急犯案
權力還挺大的
他有現在換成section 338
或者換成section 301
他都可以有很多工具
比方說section 301是更加針對
Pacific國家比方說針對中國
他可以用其他的
這個引用其他的section
去去做這個關稅的事情
那你要走
不停的走很多的call cases
我覺得時間會很長
就是這個時間
用call cases都是時間很長的
所以最後拖下去
就是說他特朗普
至少在這幾年裡面
還是能夠去做他自己
這段時間還是能夠去做
自己想做的事情
所以我覺得
就是說從行政立法
和議會上來說
對特朗普的
就是說現在表面上來看
是有利好
但是就是利好
就是可以阻止他們
但是實質上是做不到的
是不能阻止
但是在上週的話
都是一些de-escalation
都是一些減少衝突的這個信號
看上去都還是很不錯的
但是我剛剛我就說
就是我們對特朗普這個人
和他的政策
有了更加長期的看法
我是覺得比較悲觀
那比較悲觀的資金會不會流出美國
就是必然會
就是美元有一個貶值的區間要走
它不一定是對人民幣
它主要是歐元和日元
就是有一個貶值的這個趨勢
要走下去
這個貶值的趨勢是大概是
慢慢應該是down to往下
但是他這個down to往下
並不一定是一路直線下去
它有可能會脆斷
然後美元暴漲
這個美元暴漲的這個原因
我之前講過
就是因為其實美元一直下降的時候
就是一直在test測試美國的金融市場
美國的比方說股票
大家要賣掉股票
要不要賣摘圈這些東西
那麼當到了某一個程度的時候
會導致金融體系內的金融危機
但一旦導致金融危機
就反過了美元暴漲
我覺得這個是我個人看法
就是如果特朗普的政策不變
那麼大概大致是這樣一個趨勢
所以你會看到那個美元拋售
那麼現在我們走到哪一步
因為其實從一個月來看
美元已經低了5%了
那個現在我們走到哪一步
我覺得如果說是Dollar Weakness
參照2017年這種Dollar Weakness的話
現在走了第一步
也就是說我們從低了flow
就這個是投行的低了flow來看
大客戶的flow
美元的拋售現在僅限於
沒有見到實體的拋美元
實體拋美元包括賣掉
就個大客戶比方說日本央行
或者是日本什麼NOTU Bank這些傢伙
或者是境外資產大規模配置的人
去賣美元或者賣美國acquity
沒有見到大規模的這樣的做法
主要的那個美元的
就賣美國股票甚至都沒有見到
境外投資人就有
你說短期投資人的Hatch fund
賣了很多了是吧
但是比方說很多的就是
我們從我們從拱本來看
很多的大的客戶
就是境外的大客戶資產配置性的
放在美國的
包括保險公司什麼的
放在美元的
沒有看到大規模的拋售
見到了是
他們對於本幣的一個Hatch對沖
特別是對Sweden和對於UK
這些就是Stirling這些東西的Hatch
那Hatch是看到了
Hatch的比率在提高
本來我可能有Dollar Position
我不Hatch了
現在特別是年初
覺得Dollar Position就不Hatch
現在開始增加了Hatch
那麼現在還沒看到拋售
沒有看到拋售的意思就是
下面一輪如果是發生拋售
比方說美國繼續按照
這個關稅的政策走下去
是會看到拋售
看到拋售是可以美元繼續下跌
所以我覺得兩步走的話
現在走第一步
走了一半
下面一半可能會比前面一半
時間要長很多
那麼而且這個
這並不是說它一路走的
就好像股票一樣
它是中間會有很大的反彈的
比方說那個到夏季的時候
有可能會有反彈
我們現在看到有很多做空
就是在做
期權option
比方說做空美元的這些option的
這些投資人
它買了比方說一個Binary的option
那到了Binary option
現在賺了錢
它row
就是比方說本來是6個月
現在我把它6個月的N1掉
再去買6個月
但它現在6個月N1掉
它賺了錢
它沒有再row下去
其實在等這個summer時間
有很多這些這些投資人
他已經out of market已經走掉了
他可能休假去了
所以會有一個pulse
我是覺得多頭空頭都會有個pulse的
就是都會有個暫停的
現在空頭也會有個暫停
但是所有的股票類的外匯類的債券不太一樣
債券跟看公益面
就股票類的外匯類的
所以這些風險頭存的
其實本質上到最後還是都要看
這個美國的政策層面
那麼在政策層面
就是我是相對來說
我是一個比較悲觀的人
就是對於那個特朗普之間
關係政策比較悲觀
所以並不是說
我們應該把所有的頭存
我沒有把所有頭存全清掉原因
因為我確實也不知道
它到底會幹嘛
然後它也可以隨時反投
那麼但是就是
我是覺得如果說
它的這個政策是堅持
真正能夠影響它政策的
是要至少要拿回眾議院
才有可能影響到它的政策
你不要說把它緊急法案取消
你現在眾議院沒有投票通過
取消不了的
所以這個兩年裡面
它是可以折騰挺多的
特別是第一年
它的折騰是可以很厲害的
只要知道它折騰出衰退來
這個折騰都是可以很厲害的
那麼在這個事情的過程當中
它的政策會來來回歸的變化
因為它確實是沒有做好準備
但是這個變化的過程
也是它不停的完善自己政策的過程
而不是它轉向的過程
這個是我個人的看法
這不一定正確
但是我覺得更像戰爭中間
大家已經開打了俄國和烏克蘭打仗一樣
我準備是閃機戰
我沒有做好準備閃機戰
那我現在打下去
那我就採取不同的政策
修修補補繼續打
而不是修修補補直接和談
就是和直接結束
我覺得這是兩種方法
就是但是我覺得修修補補
繼續打的個案率會更大一點
就是它政策沒有做好準備
而進行調整
不停的在中間補漏洞
補bug
然後這個過程會走得比較通貨
比較漫長
所以這個是我對於政策層面一個看法
所以導致我就覺得幾個方面
美元會繼續變質
直到發生危機
發生危機它保長
然後acquity
現在的這個earning裡面
科技股相對來說
更相對安全一點
但是整體S&P的earning
S&P的估值還是過高
這個事情我上週講過
就是如果你衰退
那麼整體估值還是會過高的
那麼聯儲不要太去期望
因為前上週的話
那個wash講話
大家覺得可能聯儲下一任會好
但是還沒有下一任
你要把接票換掉
沒那麼換不了的
所以聯儲在至少在這一段時間裡面
這一年你也出不了手
所以就是我覺得
這個市場是會一個非常正當的市場
但是趨勢性是往下的
不是往上的
這個我可能看法
那麼除非直到特朗普的政策出來
改變我的看法
沒有這個東西出來
我不太會改變
好吧
我們今天講多了五分鐘
我們Q&A一下吧
看看大家有什麼有什麼問題
我們可以Q&A一下